can Samsung's new galaxy book 3 Pro with
Intel's 13th generation chips destroy
Apple's M2 MacBook Air well today we
will find out because we're gonna
compare the design the displays the
speakers the ports the performance and
more now the M2 MacBook Air is one of my
favorite Macs out there I absolutely
love it it does have some limitations
and I really wish they made a 15 inch
size which we might see soon I've been
asking for that for a while but Samsung
just released this this thing looks like
the previous generation MacBook Air it
has that wedge sheath the keyboard looks
like an Apple keyboard even the
fingerprint button looks identical to
the trackpad this little cutout right
here I mean look at this thing it's
almost like Samsung said well they have
a new design so we'll just take their
old design and we'll run with it now I
don't blame name them it looks good but
it is a little sucks now the M2 MacBook
Air got rid of that wedge it has this
flat design like a slate design very
nice and thin it has a little bit of
Curves on the bottom to make it feel a
little bit Slimmer but this thing's
actually lighter at
2.58 pounds both these have 16 gigs of
RAM and the Mac s512 whereas with the
Samsung they're upgrading you to a
terabyte right now during the pre-launch
but then they won't now I had a hard
time choosing do I compare it to the M2
air or the 14 inch MacBook Pro because
Samsung even though they just launched
it they are lowering the price so
they're giving you a terabyte for free
now with the MacBook here you guys saw
the MSRP it's quite expensive but
there's also great deals out there we'll
link that down in the description below
so I think this is the most Fair kind of
fight now if you want to compare the
Samsung with the 14 inch M2 Pro Bend
MacBook Pro let us know in the comments
and make sure to subscribe drive this
Samsung has a 14 inch display the
MacBook airs they call it 13 it's
actually about 13 and a half of course
it has that notch in there for that
1080p webcam which we'll be comparing to
this 1080p which somehow fits into this
super slim bezel now as far as the
quality I'm really surprised by this it
feels insanely lightweight but there's
very little chassis Flex it's made out
of metal feels very durable but the
screen itself is a little bit wobbly
compared to the MacBook Air way more
dense it feels a bit heavier a little
bit higher quality but this is not bad
now one thing that's interesting about
this Samsung well first off it does have
a little bit of a larger footprint as
you guys could see right there just like
the M1 MacBook Air but on the bottom we
have these speakers now this thing does
have quad speakers which we will test
out but it can fire off of the desk
which is great but if it's on your lap
of course that can get muted now we also
have some cutouts right here and that's
because this does have a fan in there or
maybe two I actually didn't look whereas
the M2 air is completely fanless now
that might mean that this uh chip the 13
gen in here could suck some good power
so we will see if it performs the same
when it is unplugged as it does when it
plugs in like the Macs do now on the
sides we also have some differences in
terms of ports here on the right hand
side the Mac just has that headphone
jack compared to having a full on USB
type A even those things so slim and a
Micro SD card slot which is awesome on
the left side both of these have two
Thunderbolt ports which is great the Mac
has that Max a charger which is magnetic
and really sweet and the Samsung has an
HDMI port which is very useful so for
ports I would give the win to Samsung
now they also managed to fit in a 63
watt hour battery in here compared to 52
in the MacBook Air and with that the
charger that they give you is impressive
this thing puts out 65 watts compared to
Apple's 67 that you get if you upgrade
some of the specs from the base and it
is so much smaller in fact it's actually
even smaller than Apple's 30 watt
charger that comes with the base one
while outputting more than double now as
far as the keyboard feel the macbook's
magic keyboard feels great but the
Samsung it feels like Apple's butterfly
keyboard has a very very shallow travel
it's a lot more kind of that clicky
clacky but not in a good way feel I'm
very surprised that they seems like they
even took that part of it now the
trackpad Max are the best you have an
even feel that you can adjust because
it's powered with magnets Samsung's is a
standard diving board design like like
the old 2017 MacBook Air but it is very
responsive to the touch and if you're
just using tapping it does work quite
well now before I move on I want to
share our sponsors really useful app
clean my Mac X I bought it three years
ago because it's a simple but powerful
way to speed up your Mac now you can
delete files and junk manually but it
takes a long time to go through folders
and Mac leaves a lot of hidden files and
the same thing when you're uninstalling
apps but clean my Mac X does it quickly
and deletes everything including system
related files it could also auto update
apps which is really useful and scan and
delete malware now their lens tool is
super cool because it visually shows you
large files which help me find a 55
gigabyte phone backup that I forgot
about the assistant recommendations are
also really useful and they have a menu
that gives you a lot of very good info
about your Mac and you can use it to
quickly free up memory to speed up your
programs and clean my Mac X can also
clean up your cash monitor Health clean
your disk and much more go ahead and use
the link in the description for a
special offer to boost and protect your
Mac and now let's go ahead and compare
the speakers like it showed you guys the
Samsung has those bottom firing speakers
but they show a quad speaker setup on
their website so that hopefully they're
spread out compared to the MacBook that
also has quad speakers but they fire
from underneath the display towards the
top
bring me back
[Music]
wow guys that was sad I actually had to
go back and double check to make sure
that these speakers were all the way
turned up which they are why advertise a
great speaker system when it doesn't
sound great at all it sounds like a
laptop you have from three four years
ago whereas the MacBook has much better
base the highs it sounds better overall
now as far as the displays the Samsung
has an AMOLED display that they show off
setting this up in dark mode out of the
box that means it's an advanced OLED
they show 2x on their website and on
this little sticker it is slightly
higher resolution than the MacBooks
which is great and it also supports 120
hertz that can dynamically switch to 60
hertz as well so it's not as good as
promotion but the M2 MacBook Air does
not have Pro machine at all it's stuck
to 60 hertz and as far as the brightness
both of them reach 500 nits and the
Samsung matches the macbook's DCI P3
color accuracy which is awesome now
since the MacBook uses an LCD display
you would think that OLED would have
much better contrast and colors but
looking at it the macbook's contrast
looks quite a bit better and the colors
look slightly better as well playing hdr
on both now that is because the Samsung
has a much more reflective display than
the MacBook looking at it I basically am
seeing a mirror right here and because
of that the contrast gets lower now the
highs do pop a little bit more so that
part of it does look good but overall
the MacBooks LCD looks more like what
you would expect Nola to left eye with
deep dark shadows and also keep in mind
with an OLED if you're going to color
calibrate it you have to keep the
brightness levels the same or the colors
do tend to shift more so and now let's
get into performance I want to start out
by testing out the ssds I have Crystal
this Mark and then amorphous dismark
over opened up right here which is just
support to Mac of course we have 512
compared to one terabyte and since
they're upgrading you for free what
speed do you get and look at that wow
that is fast as far as read speeds the
Samsung is 50 faster and in terms of
write speeds 65 faster that's a huge
difference so they didn't cheap out now
it is weird that the large block random
reads are half the speed but for
everything else it beats it out and
remember with the MacBook if you're
buying the base T56 gig that thing is
half the performance now of course that
might not tell the whole story because
of SLC cash so I'm going to take RPC
test project folder and I'm going to
start my stopwatch over here so we can
see how long it takes to transfer from a
super fast Thunderbolt SSD now we are
still plugged in and I do have Windows
set to the best performance but
unfortunately we're not moving very fast
and I can hear a high pitch wine from
the fans it sounds like there's two of
them in here that now spun up to do this
transfer and now it's time to test the
MacBook I'll start my timer wow that
took a minute and 11 seven seconds very
interesting and now it's time to test
out geekbench six yes I said geekbench 6
they released a new version it's a lot
more accurate more accurate for
cross-platform testing here we have our
MacBook which has four performance cores
and four efficiency cores compared to a
12 core i7 Raptor Lake now this thing
goes up to five gigahertz compared to
3.48 on the Mac so it should be an easy
win right well both have 16 gigs of RAM
and let's go ahead and test out our CPU
Benchmark alright guys here are the
scores and wow is it close now in terms
of single core score the MacBook beats
out the Intel Raptor Lake by 18 and a
half percent but in multi-core score the
Intel based Samsung is slightly faster
here and that is very impressive now
what I was really curious about out was
is the Samsung going to perform the same
when it's on battery power so let's go
ahead and unplug this I'm going to make
sure that we're set to the best
performance in Windows and let's run
this again now what's crazy is that's
showing an hour and 51 minutes of
battery life remaining when we're doing
this even though the battery is pretty
much fully charged that means that you
should not expect crazy battery life
with this the MacBook under the same
conditions is going to last about six
hours with that M2 Chip and it's a good
thing that on Samsung's website they
don't say that it gets 24 hours battery
all they're saying is long lasting
battery life all day long so that's an
improvement well look at this my
goodness I was not expecting this that
is a big drop in performance on battery
the previous gen well the performance
stayed about the same on the systems but
now these new Chips they're pushing them
harder and they can't keep up the
MacBooks 98 30 7 is about 44 better
performance now compared to 6800 when
you unplug this machine and that sucks
now I understand on this fat thick
laptop like the MSI Titan that we
covered which can reach over 200 watts
of CPU power but on a thin and light
laptop like this that is insane let's
plug this thing back in here because we
now know that it needs it uh to perform
and let's go ahead and compare the
graphics performance oh my goodness guys
the graphic score is basically double in
favor of the MacBook for compute tasks
that is crazy and now I want to just
test it one time unplugged and it looks
like the score does drop but not by that
much roughly uh 10 15 or so but the
MacBook on battery performs phenomenally
in terms of graphics and I have 3D
Mark's Wildlife extreme unlimited opened
up right here which I'm going to run it
is off screen so the resolution
difference doesn't matter and here are
the results having the Samsung plugged
in we got 22.16 frames per second
compared to 34.3 so the MacBook has 55
better frames per second when it comes
to gaming now of course there's not a
lot of games that are well optimized we
do have some newer ones coming out so
there's some hope for the future but the
Samsung is not a great gaming machine
either now I just noticed something that
is very odd this Samsung display seem to
be dim for some reason I went ahead and
I checked my brightness it's all the way
maxed out check the settings there's
nothing that's limiting it it's plugged
in here but the screen dimmed on me
which we haven't seen for a long time
sometimes old smartphones used to do
that when they got hot but previously
you guys saw the screens looked
identical but now the MacBook screen is
way brighter because it stays full
brightness even on battery we started
this test at like 35 battery we're still
at 18 but this thing look how dim it
looks that's something that a lot of
reviewers just don't mention I'm gonna
dim down the display here to match up
with this one or at least closer to it
and now we're going to test out
web-based application performance I have
a design project here using figma that's
brought To Us by 500 designs one of the
best Design Studios out of Los Angeles
let's see how well things load up here
I'm going to zoom in in we have
pixelation
three about three three and a half
seconds to load up that high resolution
image on the MacBook it seems to
actually be taking longer this time
we've tested in the past should be about
three seconds too with that said the
Samsung does have Wi-Fi 6E with better
antennas so it has faster Wi-Fi now I've
selected 12 high resolution layers here
and we are going to go ahead and Export
them and see how long it take to render
that took two minutes and 27 seconds
with the Raptor Lake Intel based system
plugged in compared to a minute 53 on
the Mac M2 Chip on battery now if the
Samsung was unplugged we'll take about
longer because the CPU performance gets
dropped so that's a big difference where
even in geekbench the initial plug-in
numbers looked the same now I also ran
speedometer 2.0 to check out the web
browsing performance running JavaScript
and the MacBook is 50
faster or quicker so as far as web
browsing and web-based applications it
definitely wins out even just being on
battery power now while I suspect that
most people that buy the Samsung are
going to use it for web browsing I do
want to run a few tougher tests I've
seen a bench opened up right here
because I want to see how much power
does this Raptor Lake processor really
suck so let's go ahead and run cinebench
R23 I'm gonna do just a single run here
and oh my goodness 60 watts Peak on this
chip now the Mac uh peaked at 25 watts
for a split second now it's running at
about 20 compared to about well this is
throttling down 38 32 is moving all over
the place definitely getting quite hot
the high-pitched fans are starting to
spin up on this thing both of them are
throttling now the MacBook is fanless so
it does end up dropping in wattage
performance drops a bit but not by a
crazy amount because efficiency actually
goes up on the M2 Chip just like on this
Intel so running at 2.4 gigahertz or so
compared to about three gigahertz here
so those High clock speeds in high
wattage is just good for that geekbench
score where you have short bursts but
when you get down to it it has to
Throttle Down and we have our scores and
we got 8083 on the Samsung compared to
7840 on the Macbook so it did get a
lower score now you guys see how the
wattage ended up dropping down to almost
15 watts here so average doubt in the
center about 18 19 or so compared to
this one about 25 to 28. now just for
fun I'm going to unplug this I'll reset
the minimums here and let's just see how
it acts when it's on battery and now
look at that we peaked at 45 watts
compared to 60 before and it's
throttling down much quicker than before
and we have
76.47 about 200 points lower than the
MacBook and so it's not a huge
difference not like we saw before in
geekbench 6 but now let's go ahead and
plug this back in and we'll do a real
world performance test this is Adobe
Lightroom classic for photo editing and
I have 50 high resolution images here
switching through them performance is
about the same looks like our MacBook
finally gave us the low battery sign
we're at 10 battery life it's amazing
how much we did about three hours or
more of testing and shooting here crazy
battery life I'll go ahead and plug it
in and let's go ahead and Export these
50 edited raw images to jpeg alright
guys the Samsung said two minutes and
one second compared to a minute and 13
for the fanless MacBook Air and of
course this would go slower if you had
it unplugged whereas this even though
it's plugged in the performance stays
the same so even though in some cases
the raw performance might seem to match
up or even exceed it
um in reality the real world performance
tests show that the MacBook smokes
Intel's Raptor Lake even plugged in so
that is pretty crazy Intel came to
defeat Apple's M2 Chip with their new
efficiency cores a lot of threads and
all of that stuff but in reality when it
really comes down to it the performance
is much better on the MacBook the
battery life is much better in the
MacBook the speakers are better the
display even though it's LCD it also has
its benefits a lot less reflectivity
better contrast so in reality this is
not a bad laptop I love how thin it is I
love the MacBook style design with that
wedge shape but if I had to put my money
somewhere it would be the MacBook unless
you have some application that
absolutely has to run genuine Windows on
it you guys let me know your thoughts
down in the comments section below check
out clean my Mac X and click that Circle
above to subscribe check out one of
those videos and I'll see you in the
next one
foreign